let's move on to rebel wilson she's
speaking out after an australian
journalist admitted that he gave her a
two-day deadline to comment on her new
relationship with girlfriend ramona
arguma before he planned to out her yeah
following rebels coming out announcement
on instagram last week it appears as
though she may have been persuaded i
mean sounds like forced by an australian
newspaper a columnist for the sydney
morning herald named andrew hornery
wrote an opinion piece stating
it was an abundance of caution and
respect that this media outlet emailed
robin rebel wilson's representatives on
thursday morning giving her two days to
comment on her new relationship with
another woman l.a leisurewear designer
ramona aguruma before publishing a
single word yes and andrew added that it
was a big mistake rebel decided to quote
gazump the story by posting about her
new disney princess on instagram
and elsewhere in the piece andrew
claimed that the article outing rebel
wouldn't have been that big of a deal
since sexual orientation is no longer
something to be eat to be hidden even in
hollywood i'm glad he feels that way and
no surprise andrew and the newspaper
quickly came under fire as social media
users slammed them online with many
saying it was unacceptable and appalling
i can think of a few other words to put
pressure on people to come out if he
didn't think it was a problem why'd he
give a two-day notice
rebel shared a brief message on twitter
replying to a tweet about the matter
saying
thanks for your comments it was a very
hard situation but trying to handle it
with grace
now since the outrage andrew in the
newspaper have apologized in a new
column on monday saying he did not seek
to out rebel what were you trying to do
but he understands why the email to her
team may have been seen as a threat
adding the framing of it was a mistake
i'd say
and as an openly gay man himself andrew
continued to say this i genuinely regret
the rebel has found this hard that was
never my intention but i see she has
handled it with extraordinary grace as a
gay man i'm well aware of how deeply
discrimination hurts the last thing i
would ever want is to do is uh inflict
the pain on someone else dallas
i hate everything about this because
clearly his in this newspaper's
intention i firmly believe from what
i've read and seen
was to out her you have two days
that is almost like a threat in my eyes
if you don't then we're running this
story
and as a queer person
nobody should ever be forced to come out
ever ever ever i get a lot of people who
ask me for their advice on coming out
and i always tell them
do not feel pressured and do it at your
own pace
because there's a lot of variables if
you're a child living with parents and
you want to come out to them
that is your choice but you do have to
be prepared that
they may not accept it at first or they
may lovingly accept it and for a second
or understand it but for somebody like
rebel who's has this great career
and maybe wasn't ready to go public with
this and that is her own personal
decision and they did this to get
clicks to make headlines to have people
visit their website and read that paper
and to me that is
absolutely disgusting no i agree with
you 100 i have nothing more to add that
to that i i agree and i also think she
handled it with such grace absolutely um
but hopefully there were lessons learned
there i mean i feel like these lessons
should have been learned 20 years ago
and then for him for them to say like
it's not that big of a deal to you to
you yeah you don't know how who her
family is and how they're going to react
does her family know was she ready to
tell her family and friends yeah we have
a couple comments here did you want to
sure
be bean says i do not accept that
so-called apology me neither fulani says
why are we still outing people in 2022
you know what i wish i knew
i don't understand it no i think the
world has gone a little did they figure
she was a public person and that people
would see her like well i i don't i just
don't understand and you know why it
doesn't even matter i don't think we'll
ever understand and i think it just
really does come down to
wanting to break the story
and to me that is incredibly sad because
like i said someone's life that's
someone's life yeah and it should be a
beautiful moment it should be right you
know it still is a beautiful moment but
we love you rebel yeah we do we love you
rebel